let's bring in our panel kimberly
strassel member of the editorial board
at the wall street journal steve hayes
editor of the dispatch and harold ford
jr former tennessee congressman ceo of
empowerment and inclusion capital i
would venture a guest kimberly you're
not going to see this topic discussed on
other channels
and other places but your thoughts on
this development what it means big
picture
yeah you already see other channels
dismissing this and suggesting that this
house somehow shows that durham has
coming up short without much much as
they predicted but the reality is this
is kind of an important deal because
let's not forget that the dnc and
hillary clinton used this law firm
to essentially hide
the payments that they were making to
fusion gps in this opposition research
and so what you essentially have is an
indictment of an operative here of the
clinton campaign being indicted for
going to the fbi
uh lying to them in an effort to
manipulate the fbi into investigating a
rival campaign
i think if this was flipped on its head
and this was republicans who did this
it'd be front pages everywhere but it
should be treated as an important moment
yeah steve
where do we think this is going for a
lot of these investigations there is for
people who follow it frustration that it
never ends up in anything
is this something
yeah we need to know more i mean
certainly this is something um it's
never a good idea to lie to the fbi it's
certainly not a good idea to lie to the
fbi in an effort to conceal the fact
that you're working
with a political campaign that may have
been feeding bad information to the u.s
government
we'll see where this goes obviously his
attorneys have put out a statement
saying that this is wrong that he hasn't
committed a crime i'm very interested to
learn to see if we we see from john
durham something that attempts to put
this puzzle piece in a broader picture
so that we could properly understand it
but the story itself is certainly not a
good development for
the justice department for
for michael sussman for the clinton
campaign
harold we're told that durham as the way
he operates
is very deliberate sometimes it takes
time sometimes it takes years uh that's
obviously not satisfying for the for the
trump folks who wanted it to happen
before the election but politically
the upside for the biden folks perhaps
is the merrick garland attorney general
is letting this go forward it doesn't
seem like they're stepping in the way of
any of this
it appears it appears that way thanks
for having me on i don't i don't
disagree with anything that's been said
and don't know much
that i can add other other than to just
echo that this is a serious charge
i've heard those on our network a little
earlier perhaps even a few days ago say
that they didn't think that mr durham
would bring just this charge that he was
probably angling for something else but
this is the charge that he has brought
we'll see the defense from
mr sussman and um we'll let it go from
there but i would imagine to your point
bret that the attorney general is is not
is allowing this to proceed with without
any uh any interference i want to turn
to afghanistan and these questions about
who made the final decision
was president biden kind of out on a
limb on this decision about the exit and
how it happened uh take a listen to the
white house briefing today
did the president
hear specifically the recommendation
from the commander on the ground in
afghanistan that he feared that a full
withdrawal would be
devastating and should not happen he was
provided a range of advice is it's
crystal clear that 2500 troops would not
have been sustainable
on the ground it would have been either
increased troops on the ground or
withdraw troops on the ground he was not
going to send thousands and thousands
more troops to fight a war the afghans
did not want to fight themselves but
kimberly that's the straw man is the
that wasn't the offer and uh from
everything we're getting about general
miller the commander on the ground and
what he recommended and perhaps what
other military advisers were
recommending
uh it was something short of that
yeah i mean the disconnect here all
along is that president biden has been
blaming the military for decisions that
were made there and we're saying hey
this was the best advice and i was just
doing what they told me to do it's on
them if it went wrong but the reality is
and and this you know puts it in better
context is that the president is always
in charge of setting the mission um and
essentially what the military is saying
is that within the parameters he had
given us we didn't have any choice we
had to make that there weren't any
options now we told him you could do it
this way instead and he said no that
won't fit with the mission and so that's
where we got where we got it's on biden
it's it's and he made the call yeah and
obviously that hearing we will get to
september 28th with chairman of the
joint chiefs mark milley uh steve this
will be a major question but as will
obviously the woodward costa book and
all the allegations there
yeah i think we can bet on a number of
questions about the woodward costa book
and the firestorm or the past 36 hours
on this question look
the us military leadership on the ground
in afghanistan
made plenty of mistakes and i think gave
plenty of bad advice over the years they
downplayed the the existence of al qaeda
in country they whitewashed some of the
taliban they did that in public settings
they did that certainly in private
settings but i think kimberly is right
this is ultimately joe biden's call and
there were certainly intelligence
assessments that said to the president
if you withdraw u.s troops if you reduce
the american presence on the ground in
afghanistan it will have negative
effects on what's happening there and
will will hurt our ability certainly to
collect more intelligence so that's on
joe biden